what happens if the mullah report comes
up empty plus we recap the HW Bush
tribute ceremony and discuss whether
gender-reveal parties are cysts
normative i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
in just a second we're gonna recap the
tribute ceremony that was held in
Washington DC yesterday for George HW
Bush the 41st president of the United
States we're also going to go through
the latest in the Muller report because
the fact is that more and more
information keeps leaking and there's
this feeling that it's leading to a
final conclusion here so we'll preview
all of that but first let's talk about
your sleep quality so you already have a
nice mattress you already have good
aeration in your room
everything is very comfortable except
your sheets you're wondering why you're
sweating through your sheets at night
it's because your sheets are crappy
right all you did is you went down to
the local Bed Bath & Beyond you bought
the thing with the highest thread count
but you didn't think about the materials
in there you didn't think about the
breathability or quality of the sheets
you just bought whatever was on the
shelf this was a mistake instead you
should have gone to bowl and branch
everything bull and branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton which means they
start out supersoft they get even softer
over time you can actually buy directly
from them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices these are luxury sheets
that can cost up to a thousand dollars
in the store but Boleyn branch sheets
that are only a couple of hundred bucks
I mean these are really high quality
sheets everyone who tries Boleyn branch
loves them it's a reason I got rid of
all my old sheets and bought only bull
and branch even three u.s. presidents
sleep on bull and branch eats to get you
started right now my listeners can get
50 bucks off your first set of sheets at
bull and branch com promo code been
shipping is free can try them for 30
nights if you don't like them you have
nothing to lose
go to bull and branch calm today for 50
bucks off your first set of sheets
that's bol and branch calm promo code
Ben go check it out right now
alrighty so we begin today with a recap
of the ceremony held for George HW Bush
in the Capitol rotunda
yesterday and it was I think very
meaningful very nice ceremony people
filing past the the casket of George HW
Bush American Hero and 41st presidents
of the United States Donald Trump came
by to pay a visit that saluted the
coffin president george w bush of course
was there it was quite moving to watch
george w bush saluting his father
obviously the the AP says the nation's
capitol embraced george HW bush and
death monday with solemn ceremony and
high tributes to his service and decency
as the remains of the 41st president
took their place in the capitol rotunda
for three days of mourning and praised
by the political elite and everyday
citizens alike with bush's casket atop
the lincoln
catafalque first used for Abraham
Lincoln's 1865 funeral dignitaries came
forward to honor the Texan whose efforts
for his country extended 3/4 of a
century from World War 2 through his
final years as an advocate for
volunteerism and relief for people
displaced by natural disaster obviously
President George HW Bush died on Friday
at age 94 a bunch of luminaries paid
tribute to him Representative Paul Ryan
said here lies a great man and a gentle
soul his legacy his grace perfected Vice
President Mike Pence spoke President
Trump did not speak which is probably a
smart move knowing that it would just be
politicized immediately anyway here's a
little bit of Vice President Mike Pence
given what I think was one of his finest
speeches of his political career in
tribute to George HW Bush all of his 94
years President Bush never lost his love
of adventure and he never failed to
answer the call to serve this country
when President George Herbert Walker
Bush left office he left America and the
world more peaceful prosperous and
secure President Bush was a great leader
who made a great difference in the life
of this nation but he was also just a
good man who was devoted to his wife his
family and his friends we had a
discussion yesterday we had a special
that was me and Jeremy boring and Andrew
Klavan and for some reason Michael moles
and we were talking about George HW Bush
and it strikes me that it is much harder
in life to actually be a good man than
it is to be a great man to be a great
man meaning a remembered person a person
who shaped the lives and millions of
people requires a couple of things you
have to be in a position of power and
you have to be in a position where a
crisis is sort of thrust upon you and we
think of the great leaders in American
history we think of George Washington or
Abraham Lincoln who had to ride out the
civil war or FDR who had to ride out
World War two in the great depression we
tend to think of Ronald Reagan who faced
down the Soviet Union a lot of being
great is sort of a response to
circumstance Winston Churchill facing
down the Nazis in World War two but
being a good man is a different thing
and I think George HW Bush I'm not sure
that he was a great man in the sense
that he shaped the lives of millions of
people and and was will be considered an
important world leader in the great span
of history but I think he was a
very good man and being a good man is a
lot more difficult in a lot of ways
because it means more anonymity it means
a certain level of humility like to be a
great president it used to be that being
a great president required many of the
qualities of being a good man it used to
be the being a great president required
humility electoral humility legislative
humility a feeling that you were there
to guard and protect but not to change
that basically your job was to be a
manager a caretaker so Calvin Coolidge
in my opinion a great president and a
good man and I think there was crossover
between being humble and not needing to
be in the spotlight all the time and not
being concerned with being seen as a
great moral visionary or somebody
transforming the country and then as
government grew and as government became
more powerful and as we started to
abandon a lot of our social institutions
we stopped looking for the good people
in our own life to model our behaviors
after and instead we started looking for
the great man to lead us and that has
required a different set of people to be
presidents of the United States people
who may not be as good in general people
who do have sort of world-beating
ideological visions people who are not
as concerned with simply managing
America and keeping out of harm's way
and staying out of everybody's business
and much more are interested in shaping
the country transforming the country
fundamentally rewriting the country that
that's a tragedy for the country and it
also it gives a lie I think it it
demonstrates that being a good man and
being a great president not the same
thing but being a good man is again
harder you know it's interesting I was
reading a book by famous rabbi and he
was specifically talking about why there
are so many famous rabbis in the past
who didn't write books many many famous
rabbis are not known for their writing
they're known for sort of their old
lectures that were taken down by people
who would transcribe them rabbi Joseph
soloveitchik very famous rabbi talked
about this he said that one of the
reasons that he didn't write more is
because he felt it was an act of
arrogance because he was just one person
in the great span of history and too
arrogantly ascribe his beliefs to a name
to try and outlive himself would be an
act of arrogance being good requires
making all the daily decisions that make
your family stronger to do all the
things on a daily level that nobody's
going to know about yeah it's very funny
whenever we talk about the folks in our
lives who who made a big difference we
say things like well you know my dad
and who and I my father I mean like when
we talk about our own parents we tend to
say things like my parents are great and
that's what really counts because that's
what will be remembered but the truth is
that won't be remembered three
generations from now three generations
from now I don't think that the that the
actions that my grandfather took her my
great-grandfather took will be
remembered I'm not sure that people
remember much about my great-grandfather
I don't I certainly didn't know the man
um but I do know that all of the small
actions that he took led to this time
and so being a good man in many cases is
what keeps civilization going while
being a great man may keep civilization
alive in times of crisis it requires
good men to prevent those crises in the
first place I think George HW Bush was a
very good man
even if I'm not sure that he was a great
president okay well with all of that
said the left has decided that they
can't stand all the warm feelings for
George HW Bush at least some members of
the left so we've gotten the dumbest
versions of the left coming out and
saying incredibly stupid things the
stupidest thing yesterday was this
article from Slate about Sully HW Bush
okay so this dog Sully is a service dog
and there's a picture that was going
around of the service dog that was lying
near the president's casket and
according to media I they're part of
president's Labrador Retriever had
captivated political observers from last
few days of the nation mourns the
ex-presidents passing people became
particularly enamored with the dogs
thanks to a dog thanks to a widely
circulated photo of him lying in front
of his owners casket thus slate
published a piece titled don't spend
your emotional energy on Sully HW Bush
so now there is not enough to attack HW
we got to attack his dog so Ruth Graham
writes a piece talking about how this
dog only knew George HW Bush for six
months on Sunday night George HW Bush
spokesman Jim McGrath posted a
photograph to Twitter depicting a golden
Labrador named Sully rusting in front of
the former presidents casket the caption
read mission complete within within
hours somebody the dog had become a bona
fide celebrity McGrath sentiment has
been retweeted 61 thousand times in
Counting and Sully was trending on
Twitter at various times on Monday
c-span covered the dogs arrival at Joint
Base Andrews Maryland on Monday
afternoon the picture of the dog lying
in front of the casket was covered by
outlets from Fox News to NPR but but
this is not reality
many suggested Sully was heartbroken or
the
they themselves were crying over the
photo conservative writer Dan mcLaughlin
compared the dog to a Marine there's
nothing wrong with applying
sentimentality when it comes to family
pets reacting to their owners death but
Sully is not a longtime Bush family pet
letting go of the only master he has
known he's an employee who served for
less than six months hey if this is how
you spent your day writing this thing
piece for slate may I suggest that you
find another line of calling my goodness
Sully's Instagram account in several
mainstream news outlets referred to him
as Sully HW Bush his bio also says he's
making his forever home at walkers point
but Monday morning just a few days after
his owner died Bush's son George W Bush
announced that Sully is heading to his
next assignment Walter Reed National
Military Medical Center in Maryland
because he's an ambassador for a New
York based nonprofit called America's
vet dogs which trains guide and service
dogs for military veterans it's
wonderful for Bush had a trained service
animal like Sully available to him in
its last month but it's a bit too mented
to project soul wrench and grief on to a
dog's decision to lie down in front of a
casket and now listen I'm not a dog
person and I don't own a dog I'm not a
person who by and large likes dogs but
if you are like ripping on a service dog
for lying in front of the casket of a
master that he just served for six
months
that's pretty demented that's pretty
demented but that was not the only
evidence of the left being demented
yesterday joy behar who is just out of
her mind she apparently took it upon
herself to bash president Trump during a
segment about George HW Bush because
this is really what the Left wanted to
do I mean the reality is what the left
really wanted out of this whole George
HW Bush spectacle out of the entire hey
geographer George HW Bush was to rip on
President Trump that's the we talked
about this yesterday they wanted to
juxtapose the class and goodness of HW
Bush with President Trump who is not the
classiest best dude right that was their
whole goal here so joy behar started to
go off on it and Meghan McCain basically
stopped her cold this president that we
have now is trying to unravel everything
that he did and Obama did and if I ever
become a one-issue voter it will be
about pollution and the greenhouse
effect and we focus on the president
please I don't want to talk about
traveling
we're honoring a please I want to talk
about honoring but I'm not interested in
your one Asia when Whoopi Goldberg is
jumping in to stop the fight then you
know things have gone wildly wrong
apparently it got even worse according
to a source they told the Daily Mail
that Behar threw her hands in the air as
soon as the producers muted Behar's mic
they they actually muted Behar's mic
because she would not get under control
and the source told Daily Mail Behar
threw her hands in the air and yelled my
god and get this B word under control
and she said if this bleep doesn't stop
I'm quitting this damn show I can't take
this much more and she says I've
tolerated a lot of bleep on the show but
I'm at my wit's end with this entitled B
word enough already enough already I'm
not playing nice any longer Behar
shouted despite the studio audience
being able to how dare Meghan McCain how
dare Meghan McCain say let's not talk
about Trump's pollution record while
we're talking about the death of George
HW Bush amazing amazing stuff will give
you more on joy Behar's demented
response to Meghan McCain in just one
second first let's talk about how you
can make your business more efficient
one of the ways you can make your
business more efficient is by not
spending an enormous amount on your
legal support business owners know that
owning your own business is not easy no
one could have prepared you for the
amount of work involved from
understanding tax law changes to
contract reviews and so much more it's
tough to do it on your own which is why
you need Legal Zoom they're there to
give you the tools you need so you can
focus on running your business Legal
Zoom is a spectacular surface it's so
good that I used it years before they
are an advertiser on the program before
the program even existed more than a
million Americans have used Legal Zoom
to start their businesses but even after
your business is set up Legal Zoom can
still help you out things like lease
agreements changing tax laws contract
reviews they're all part of running your
business these are the kind of legal
hurdles that Legal Zoom can help you
cover so you don't lose momentum at the
end of the year they even created a
business legal plan so you can get
advice for your business from vetted
independent attorneys and tax
professionals licensed in every state
the best part is you won't get charged
by the hour since Legal Zoom is not a
law firm so go visit Legal Zoom calm
right now to take care of your business
before the year winds down and for
special savings be sure to enter promo
code been in the referral box to check
out that his promo code been for special
savings only at legalzoom.com again that
is legal
zooom dot-com I love LegalZoom they're a
great sponsor and not only that they are
going to help your business
poodles I mean they really are fantastic
at what they do check them out Legal
Zoom calm and use promo code event and
check out for some special savings go
check that out right now
so Meghan McCain apparently and Joy
Behar continued to get into it
apparently make it McCain reportedly
said I don't know why she's so upset I
just wanted her to focus on President
Bush and not bring Trump into this for
once
well hair and makeup people attempted to
groom both of the hose producers tried
to calm Behar down before returning from
commercial break
everyone was frantic this according to
the Guardian they ordered the Daily Mail
the last thing they wanted was for joy
to walk off the show she's done that
before remember the Bill O'Reilly
situation she appeared just as disgusted
as she did that day they only had two
minutes to contain this explosion on set
and get everyone positioned to return
for the next live segment it was utter
chaos on set now listen I've been part
of group shows with people on the left
and sometimes those people get angry and
I've had situations where those people
have walked out of the room not naming
any names but just because that is the
way that people on the Left sometimes
act in these situations does not mean
that Joy Behar is not insane okay
George HW Bush dies she's ripping on
Trump about pollution Meghan McCain who
who knows a few things by the way about
prominent Republicans dying in the
recent past says maybe we should pay
attention to the guy who just died and
Behar loses her bleep that's because for
the left HW is just another vehicle for
attacking President Trump that's that's
really what is going on here and we all
know it and it's not just you know on
silly things like pollution the the
latest example Catherine rambles a
columnist over at the Washington Post
and she pays tribute HW Bush because HW
Bush was the last of his kind why
because he understood that tax cuts were
voodoo economics so now we're going to
praise now the idea is I guess that we
are going to praise George HW Bush for
being an establishment Republican and
you knew it was always gonna come around
to this it was gonna start with what a
classy dude that guy was I mean just
what class he was and then eventually
was going to turn into because Trump is
a jerk and also because George HW Bush
was more moderate amazing how they stain
to all these people as soon as they
leave office pretty incredible stuff
well in just a second I want to talk
about why it is that George HW Bush's
tenure eventually led to the Trump
tenure it's a long chain but here's
here's really how this began so
George HW Bush was a moderate
establishment Republican he did not see
tax cuts as spurring the economy he did
not believe the tax cuts would increase
tax receipts which they do pay the why
that it is voodoo economics the tax cuts
lead to increased tax receipts that is
just not true okay every time tax cuts
have led to increase tax receipts the
problem is we've never brought our
spending under control well because
George HW Bush was so eager to
capitulate to Democrats in 1988 to 1992
and then because george w bush cut a
bunch of deals with democrats when he
was in office and then because democrats
decided from 2008 to 2016 they were not
gonna make any deals with the
republicans and were instead going to
cram down the purest form they could get
through their own caucus on every single
issue eventually republicans said this
republican party doesn't do anything put
the guy in charge who will just wreck
things and the problem is that this has
not actually cured the republican
party's inability to get anything done
so let's be frank about this the
republican party has been in charge of
congress in charge of the house of
representatives since 2010 from 2010 to
2014 de which i think that the house
largely did then we got to 2016 through
and the republicans controlled the house
they controlled the senate and they
controlled the presidency they couldn't
even stop the funding for Planned
Parenthood and so all the talk about
Republicans and and their ability to get
things done it is Republican inability
to get things done that led to the
frustration that brought about Trump
because there were promises made and
those promises simply were not kept it's
why so many members of the base are
willing to grant President Trump a lot
of leeway because they feel like at
least President Trump is making promises
that he's attempting to keep now whether
have the problem those promises actually
been kept no but Trump I think can I
think pretty cleanly say that a lot of
those promises haven't been kept because
Republicans in the House of Senate have
not given him what he wanted so for
example Trump says I want to build the
wall the house does not fund it the
Senate does not fund it President Trump
said he was going to defund Planned
Parenthood that has not happened either
he want to make the tax cuts permanent
that did not happen either by the way
there's no excuse for the fact that the
session the congressional session ends
later this week they have a couple of
days later this week Dave some I believe
some session days next week why they're
not working while they still have it
in house I'm making the tax cuts
permanent is beyond me but they're not
doing any of that stuff and it's exactly
that sort of mentality we can't RAM
things through that'll lead to a
backlash that led to President Trump in
the first place so for all the folks who
are saying look how look how the
Republic has declined look how the
temperament has declined you know why
because in 2012 I think 2012 in a lot of
ways broke the country in 2012
Republicans ran a guy who was by many
measures extraordinarily moderate in
2008 and ran a guy who by many measures
was extraordinarily moderate both of
those guys were considered to be classy
gentlemen both of them lost and then the
Democrats said that they were not in
fact moderate there were radicals and
not only were they radical they were
remain nasty and cruel and so
Republicans responded to years and years
and years of running moderate candidate
after moderate candidate who is class
and decency year after year and then
they're like you know what we never win
and then Trump comes along since I
pledged to you I will win and then in
2016 he did win and that was taken as
evidence that all of the all of the
moderation and all of the class were
actually inhibitory to victory now I
don't think that that was a proper
conclusion to draw I think it's gonna be
classy and you can also be a knife
fighter but with that said to ignore the
history that led up to to ignore that
history did lead through the the
perception of George HW Bush as an
establishment guy to George W Bush as an
establishment guide to John McCain and
Bob Dole and Mitt Romney as
establishment guys all the way up to
Donald Trump was the anti-establishment
is to ignore the the stream of history
that led us to this point in time and
that's why there was a backlash right
Dick Cheney was talking about George HW
Bush and the partisan ranker on CNN the
other night and it is amazing to me to
watch as Republicans late to Cheney
right who spends a lot of time working
with Democrats as I mentioned Howie was
making a movie back to Cheney right now
called Vice by Adam McKay it's going to
be a hit piece on Dick Cheney about how
evil and Machiavellian he is and there's
Dick Cheney talking about well there
used to be a better time in history
those of us in the grassroots base don't
remember a better time when Democrats
actually treated Republicans well we
just think that establishment
Republicans are delusional when they
talk about this time but Dick Cheney
says no no there was a better time it
was it was so much better before not
sure that's the case all of this
all of this goodwill that we're seeing
not gonna make a difference as far as
Washington is concerned I don't know
wolf I hope so
it's you know it's a different feel when
you get this group of people around you
and we're interacting with one another
it's a well it's a warmer friendlier
we're reminiscing and so of course we're
not in charge now control of anything
but it was a different era okay so you
know again this idea it was a different
year it was different then they said all
these terrible things about HW they call
him a racist they said the same stuff
about Ronald Reagan they called him a
racist and a buffoon and a crazy person
no things were not different it's just
that Republicans were much more
conciliatory in action as well as indeed
Trump is not conciliatory in action or
deed which is why he is heavily popular
with the base and is likely to remain so
so in just a second I'm gonna get to the
latest on Russia Gate people still
hoping that that robert muller is
willing to bring down the president I'm
not so sure but we're gonna discuss the
latest allegations in just a second
first let's talk about how you can be
dressed better than anyone else at your
holiday party this year I know you're
dreading going to this company holiday
party you're thinking I don't have
anything in my closet
the last suit that I bought was in 1982
and it still has those crazy wide lapels
well you actually need a tailored suit
okay you need to look stylish you need
to look slick for that holiday party and
that is why you need to check out enzo
Chino they have a huge variety of
fabrics colors patterns Indo Chino is
incredibly stylish and again its highest
quality lowest price here's how it works
you go to one of their showrooms I went
to their one in Santa Monica and they
will then measure you they will they'll
take all your measurements like you're
going to go to a tailor in the middle of
London they ask you how you want your
lapels don't ask you how you want your
monogrammed on they ask you what
materials you want inside and outside
it's really really cool and then they
send you a fully tailored suit just for
you so you visit a stylist at the
showroom or if you're not near a
showroom then you take all your
measurements yourself and you just shop
online in Indo Chino comm submit those
measurements and then relax while your
suit gets professionally tailored and
mailed to you in a couple of weeks this
week my listeners can get any premium
Indo Chino suit for just 359 bucks at
Indo Chino calm when you enter promo
code Shapiro at checkout that's 50% off
the regular price for a made-to-measure
premium suit plus shipping is free
that's Indo Chino com promo code Shapiro
for any premium suit
just 359 Bucks free shipping incredible
deal for a premium made-to-measure suit
go check it out right now Indo Chino
calm and use that promo code Shapiro
okay so as we move forward with this
high level of loyalty by Republicans
toward president Trump we are we are
headed for a showdown over the Muller
investigation according to Michael
Isikoff reporting for Yahoo News he says
Special Counsel Robert Muller Robert
Muller's prosecutors have told defense
lawyers in recent weeks that they are
tying up loose ends in their
investigation providing the clearest
clues yet that the long-running Russia
probe in the 2016 election may be coming
to its climax potentially in the next
few weeks according to multiple sources
close to the matter the new information
about the state of Muller's
investigation comes during a pivotal
week in which the special counsels
prosecutors are planning to file memos
about three of their most high-profile
defendants former Trump national
security adviser Michael Flynn former
Trump campaign Chairman Paul Manafort
and former Trump personal lawyer Michael
Kohn a Flynt sentencing memo is due on
Tuesday memos about manna fort and cohen
are slated for friday all three
documents are expected to yield
significant new details on what
cooperation the three of them provided
to the Russia investigation there's been
a lot of speculation that Muller might
file his memo in Manta Ford's case under
sealed to prevent public disclosure of
the additional crimes his office
believes manna fort committed when he
allegedly provided two prosecutors and
broke a plea deal after agreeing to
cooperate that would be the juiciest
part the juiciest part would obviously
be what man afford lied to prosecutors
about because presumably that's his
coordination with the Trump legal team
but Peter Carr spokesman for the special
counsel confirmed to Yahoo News on
Monday the manna fort memo will be
public although he added there could be
some portions that are redacted or filed
as a sealed addendum the manna fort memo
has been requested by the federal judge
in his case so that prosecutors could
for the first time spell out what
matters they believed manna fort has
lied to them about the fact that Muller
is planning a public filing about manna
Ford suggests he may no longer feel the
needs withhold information about his
case in order to bring additional
indictments against others which means
that this thing is coming to its close
they've been telling people they're
tying up loose ends and trying to
conclude said one source familiar with
the communications between Miller's
office and defense lawyers that message
was reinforced to some degree on Monday
when Motors office talked to
congressional investigators as part of
an ongoing discussion about whether new
subpoenas for testimony
by House and Senate committees might
interfere with Muller's investigation
the response which surprised one
investigator was that it would not at
least in matters relating to obstruction
by the White House in the Russia
investigation itself what we were told
is that the investigation has reached a
mature enough stage that they basically
talked to everybody they want to talk to
you send a knowledgeable source Miller's
office is declining public comment when
asked to confirm this account so could
be that there are a few more witnesses
out by all accounts last week's guilty
plea by former Trump lawyer Michael Kohn
was one of Muller's more significant
documents Kohn is due to be sentenced in
federal court in New York next week the
only publicly known manner Muller is
believed to be focused on relates to
trump advisor Roger stone and conspiracy
theory Jerome Corsi so we're going to
find out more this week
about exactly what Muller has but all of
this raises the possibility that Muller
doesn't actually have that much either
so I know everybody's speculating the
Muller has everything but I'm not sure
that that is the case I want to get to
that theory in just a second but first
the New York Times is also reporting
that in mid May 2017 poem Anna Ford
facing intensifying pressure to settle
debts and pay mounting legal bills flew
to Ecuador to offer his services to a
potentially lucrative new client the
country's incoming president Lenin
Moreno mister manna forum made the trip
made the trip mainly to see if he could
broker a deal under which China would
invest in Ecuador's power system
possibly yielding a fat Commission for
Manta fort but the talks turns with
diplomatic sticking point between the
u.s. and Ecuador the fate of WikiLeaks
founder Julian Assange and at least two
meetings with man afford mr. Moreno and
his aides discussed their desire to rid
themselves of mr. manna fort they said
mana Ford suggested he could help
negotiate a deal for the handover of mr.
Assange to the United States which has
long investigated Assange for the
disclosure of secret documents within a
couple of days of mr. Mann affords final
meeting Robert Muller was appointed as
special counsel to investigate Russian
interference in the 2016 election and it
quickly became clear that manna fort was
a primary target there is no evidence I
love that this is buried deep down in
the New York Times article there is no
evidence that mr. manna fort was working
with or even briefing President Trump or
other administration officials on his
discussions with the Ecuadorians about
mr. Assange
so what does all of this mean when all
is said and done what does all of this
come to well it comes down to the idea
that there may not be an underlying
crime here there may be ancillary
related crimes meaning that Michael
Cohen may have lied about stuff to the
FBI while the FBI was investigating 2016
meaning the manna fort may have lied to
the FBI about ancillary matters
unrelated to the 2016 election
meaning Michael Flynn may have lied
about stuff that had nothing to do with
the 2016 election which appears to have
been the case but that doesn't go to an
underlying conspiracy to affect the 2016
election by coordinating with the
Russian government which again for the
one millionth time was the original
allegation against president Trump and
his team now that means that President
Trump should shut up really that for his
own sake
his lawyers need to tell him to stop
tweeting you stop saying things because
all he could possibly do is get himself
in further illegal trouble by creating
ancillary legal problems for himself
it's one thing to protest your innocence
it's another thing to do it so
vociferously that you verge on violating
other federal laws so yesterday
President Trump has we talked about
issued a series of tweets in which he
said that Michael Cohen should be
punished
he said he lied and should in my opinion
serve a full and complete sentence and
then he immediately followed that up by
saying that Roger stone is a good guy
for not testifying against President
Trump which sounds like maybe he is
offering a pardon to Roger stone if
Roger stone were to be prosecuted and
keeps his mouth shut but he thinks the
cone should be prosecuted to the full
extent of the law
Trump appears to be suggesting that
Muller and his angry Democrats were
seeking to suborn perjury to push Cohn
and others from Trump's orbit into lying
about Trump Russia collusion there's no
actual evidence of that Trump also seems
to be trying to affect witness testimony
or maybe he could be so George come onwe
who's the husband of Kellyanne Conway he
tweeted out file under 18 USC Section
1503 and 1512 those would be the
provisions of federal law with regard to
witness tampering all a pundit has a
long article over at hot air looking at
the applicable law in this case and this
has become a meme on the left over the
last 24 hours is that President Trump
violated the the witness tampering
statutes section 1503 which is what
Conway is referring to says whoever
corruptly or by threats or force or by
any threatening letter or communication
endeavors to influence intimidate or
impede any grin or petite juror or
officer in or of any court of the United
States or officer who may be serving at
any examination etc etc etc or corruptly
or by threats of or force or by any
threatening
letter or communication influences
obstructs or impedes or endeavors to
influence instruction or impede the due
administration of justice shall be
provided in Subsection B that's a that's
a catch-all for corrupt behavior and
then 1512 which is the other federal
section that has talked about by George
Conway is about tampering with a witness
victim or informant it says whoever
knowingly uses intimidation threatens or
corruptly persuades another person or
attempts to do so or engages in
misleading conduct toward another person
with intent to influence delay or
prevent the testimony of any person in
an official proceeding or cause or
induce any persons withhold testimony or
withhold a record document or other
object from an official proceeding could
violate the witness tampering statute
the problem here is that there's no
actual indictment out against Roger
stone at this point so he's not actively
a witness in in actual judicial
proceeding so the definition of judicial
proceeding is a little more specific
than I think folks aren't making out
here beyond that is a prosecutor really
going to going to be prosecuting on this
basis I think that is highly unlikely
that President Trump is gonna end up in
the dock from witness tampering for
tweeting out publicly that he likes a
witness who is not testifying against
him I mean he said this sort of stuff
publicly if he is not if there's no
evidence that he actually offered a
pardon if the best that they can do is
the suggestion that maybe he's covertly
offering a pardon by saying that some
people have guts and I'm glad he's not
talking to to Muller I don't think that
that counts as witness tampering under
any interpretation of law but again the
the most grave danger of the President
Trump has here is with regard to
suborning perjury or witness tampering
or some ancillary crime and those things
are a real problem there are a real
problem for presidents under
investigation I'll explain more about
that in just one second first let's talk
about the best gift you can get somebody
this holiday season I mean the best gift
your parents particularly they have a
bunch of old memories stacked up in the
garage they've got all these old films
that all these videotapes these VHS
tapes nobody's looked at them in years
they're inaccessible they're moles
wearing out there in the garage the bugs
are getting into him you need to send
them over to my friends at legacy box
and get all your old home movies films
and photos convert it to digital files
your birthdays baby's first steps
graduations weddings you can get them
all converted to a thumb drive a DVD or
even a convenient digital download for
you to easily watch and share with your
family which means that god forbid
something happens to your garage you're
not going to have to worry
about Russia I mean that used to be the
go-to answer right when the question was
there's a fire at your house what's the
first thing you grab and you always have
all the baby books
well now you no longer need to worry
about that because why would you be
schlepping 60 pound boxes out of your
garage in the middle of a fire instead
you just grab your keychain because it's
got all the information on there it's
the easiest way to get a tour done and
do something really meaningful for your
family 400,000 families have used legacy
box to preserve and relive their family
memories I've done it for my parents it
really is fantastic
legacy boxes are offering listeners 40%
off at legacy box comm /ban I think that
you can't do anything better for
somebody your memories are your life but
so legacy box comm /ban get those
memories preserved and when you use that
slash pen you get 40% off so go take
care of it right now
legacy box comm / pen that's legacy box
comm / Ben now as I say president Trump
could put himself in jeopardy due to
ancillary crime time to get to all that
in a second first go subscribe over at
daily where calm now I remind you you
love the podcast right you love being
able to coordinate with me and be part
of the mailbag and all that all the
stuffs great come January there will be
two more live hours every afternoon in
which I will be speaking to you will be
syndicated on the radio and you get the
behind-the-scenes which means when your
subscriber I'll actually be doing things
like answering questions daily in the
middle of the in the middle of the
commercial breaks because that's how
much we love you
that's how much we want to help you you
get all those goodies coming up in
January so subscribe now for all of that
you get the rest of this show live you
get the rest of clav initial live and
michael Knowles's terrible show live
yeah all of those wonderful things you
can't ask questions in our mailbag so we
need two interminable sessions about the
history of xmas then you can ask us
questions to break up the monotony you
can do all sorts of wonderful things
when you go subscribe over at daily
wire.com and with the annual
subscription comes this the very
greatest and beverage vessel the leftist
here's how to recall tumbler fill it
with eggnog this holiday season and get
drunk to ensure that you don't have to
listen to your leftist relatives
rattle on I mean this vessel makes your
life better in so many ways as I've said
before it is a leftist year's hot or
cold tumbler it keeps hot things hot and
cold things cold how does it know how
how why doesn't it why doesn't it turn
your hot drinks cold and your cold
drinks hot how does it know what to do
no one knows this mystery but you might
be able to solve it if you actually get
this the very greatest in beverage
vessels for 99
which is cheaper than the monthly
subscription also please go over and
subscribe to our YouTube and iTunes
channels leave us a review that always
helps with the rankings we have a lot of
awesome stuff coming and I can't wait to
announce it to all of you like really
excited about this stuff go subscribe
become part of the team we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so as I say on the left is is trying to
proclaim that all of the smoke from
Muller means there's fire but it seems
to me that Muller solidest ground the
most solid ground upon which Muller
stands is the idea that there are
ancillary crimes here why do I say that
because every single person who has pled
guilty to a crime has pled guilty not to
anything having to do with Russians from
collusion which was the original cause
of the investigation George papadopolis
spent 14 days in jail after a huge
investigation because he pled guilty to
lying to the FBI there is no evidence of
underlying crimes with regard to
collusion Paul Manafort pled guilty to
counts related to work for Ukrainian
politicians years ago as well as tax
issues no relation to the Trump Russia
campaign Rick Gates pled guilty to false
statements charges and to conspiracy
related to work with Ukrainian
politicians Alex vanderzwaan
pled guilty to making false statements
to the FBI about contacts with Rick
gates Michael Cohen pled guilty to tax
and bank charges as well as campaign
finance violations as well as lying to
Congress about Trump's business in
Russia none of it had to do with the
Trump Russia connection with regard to
2016 and as Andrew McCarthy wrote a
couple of days ago Muller knows the
legitimacy of his investigation is under
attack allegedly driven by politics
rather than evidence of crime but the
convictions he has amassed even if they
are only for false statements or
otherwise unrelated to the Trump Russian
rationale for the investigation proved
that many people Trump brought into his
campaign were corruptible and of low
character this means the most severe
damage for Trump lies in his own
statements to the FBI to the American
public and his behavior with regard to
other witnesses which is why the
president needs to stop tweeting
forthwith the president needs to stop
making public statements about this
forthwith he is putting himself in a
worse legal position by talking about
this than if he would just be quiet this
is the first rule of a defense lawyer if
anybody were to come to me and say the
police are investigating me what should
I tell them my answer would be shut your
face really like if you were if you were
a subject of an investigation the answer
is shut your face from a defense
perspective put aside guilt or innocence
the last thing you want is a talkative
client every lawyer knows this and the
fact that President Trump keeps
providing problems for his own folks
because he won't stop the jabbering is a
serious serious issue for him but it
does underscore the fact that Muller
still has not presented evidence of the
central contention in 2016
yes there are people who are talking
with the Russians yes there was a trump
tower meeting it still seems to be the
most important single piece of
information for the Muller case is that
Trump Tower meeting between Donald Trump
jr. and members of the campaign and this
Russian lawyer when they were supposedly
offering help from the Russian
government with regards to intelligence
about Hillary Clinton but as Eugene
Pollock has written over at The
Washington Post that is not only not
clear the criminal it doesn't even
amount to criminal conspiracy and there
may not be an underlying crime
considering nothing actually happened
from it it can all be dirty it can all
be scuzzy it can all be a problem it is
not in fact criminal and lots of dirty
and scuzzy and terrible things happen in
presidential politics as we all know so
if I had to try and forecast this I
would say that the best Democrats are
gonna be able to do is try and accuse
Trump of ancillary crimes which is why
that's exactly what they're doing ted
Lieu congressman from out here in Los
Angeles he says that President Trump is
engaged in witness tampering notice
again how the accusations against Trump
have changed originally was the Trump
colluded with Russia to steal the
election from Hillary Clinton now it's
the Trump is tampering with witnesses
via public statements on Twitter looks
to me in this case that Donald Trump is
attempting to persuade Roger stone to
keep him from testifying
if I were Special Counsel Moeller I'd
have a whole series exhibits that simply
have Donald Trump Trump's tweets pasted
on their page and we put that as you put
it broad statement on the on the screen
you think this does induce false
testimony I think it's attempt to
persuade Roger stone to not testify that
by itself would violate the witness
tampering statute okay but you know
inducement actually requires a quid pro
quo so question is what exactly is the
quid pro quo bottom line is again Trump
said stuff you shouldn't have said stuff
and now he's got trouble because he said
stuff this has been the running theme
that can you imagine how good this
presidency would be if Trump had not
created all these problems from himself
by just saying things it really it
demonstrates that a little bit of
discipline in politics goes a very long
way now again that is not to
underestimate the amount of media hatred
for him it's not to underestimate the
fact that the media have royally botched
their coverage of the Trump Russia
investigation how many false outright
false stories have been printed by the
mainstream media that they have then had
to retract about President Trump and his
supposed coordination with the
government and there's one just last
week that NPR reported and then had to
retract about supposed coordination
between Trump and Russia and WikiLeaks
there's one last year in which CNN tried
to report that Donald Trump jr. had
known in advance about WikiLeaks emails
even though the WikiLeaks emails had
actually come out before Trump juniors
coordination with anybody it's it
they've screwed this story up and and
it's so funny you see people in the
media say well yeah but we corrected it
because we're good at this that's not
the point the point is not that you
corrected it the point is whenever the
media screw up in their coverage of
Trump and Russia they only screw up in
one direction see we have the Daily wire
probably screw up in one direction 95%
of the time also
you know why because we're conservative
with an overt ideology but if CNN's job
is to objectively cover the news and
every mistake they make cuts against
Republicans and Trump you have to wonder
at a certain point whether they are not
just as ideologically driven as the
daily wire except we are significantly
more honest about our ideologically
driven news coverage okay meanwhile in
other news if you're worried about media
bias if you're worried about the social
media crackdown Tim Cook the head of
Apple made some statements that are
deeply disturbing and an ought to
disturb anyone who believes in in
freedom of opinion and free exchange of
ideas Tim Cook said that it's a sin he
allegedly said this he said at a
conference it is a sin not to ban people
from platforms 2d platform people for
hateful speech he set no limits on what
exactly hateful speech constitutes we
only had one message for those who seek
to push hate division and violence you
have no place on our platforms people
who push hate division and violence and
wanna see people who push violence agree
you wanna say hate and division okay
that's how Democrats characterize every
statement Donald Trump has ever made as
well as the majority of statements I've
ever made as well as the majority of
statements people like Charles
Krauthammer ever man everyone on the
right is suspect to people on the left
when you hear people like Tim hunt say
that sort of stuff or sorry Tim Cook say
that sort of stuff you have to wonder
are we about to experience a digital
shutdown of everybody on the right which
is why it is so vital that we have
independent platforms like my radio show
and podcast why we have an independent
platform over at Dale
why're why you should be engaging
directly with those platforms because
there will come a day and that day is
not far off it's like two years away I
think at most when Democrats are in
control of a majority of the branches of
government
maybe it's six years from now maybe
president from one's reelection whatever
it is there will come a day when there
is a Democratic president and a
Democratic Congress and they're
coordinating with Democrats in the
social media in an attempt to shut down
other points of view under the name of
preventing hate and when that happens
your sources of information will be
radically radically reduced they'll be
reduced within the ambit that the
left-wing finds palatable and that ambit
is really ugly now will they take in a
financial hit for all of this yeah they
will take a financial hit for all of
this because it turns out that when
digital media shuts down half the
audience the audience simply goes
elsewhere but that doesn't mean that it
can't completely skew the nature of
politics in the country and
unfortunately Democrats once they get
control of the levers of government they
can create incentives strong enough to
force these social media programs to
basically commit seppuku and and open
their insides out and destroy themselves
because if they don't then they'll be
regulated into oblivion that's what
Senator Dianne Feinstein of California
actually said to the heads of Facebook
if you don't regulate the news we're
gonna regulate the news and say oh my
goodness I mean then that is actual
thought tyranny in the offing so prepare
for it because it is coming sooner
rather than later okay final note today
before we get to some things I like and
things I hate this is an article from
Jennifer Finney Boylan a contributing
opinion writer over at the New York
Times
demonstrating the radicalism of the left
and prepare for things to be shut down
things that things that are normal
conversation be shut down is hateful and
terrible what is the latest example of
this well Jennifer Finney Boylan who is
a transgender woman meaning a biological
man says why our gender-reveal party's a
thing they say a lot more about our
culture than they do about the sex of
our soon-to-be children
Jennifer Boylan writes I remember when
the obstetrician revealed the genders of
our own children back in the day I
recall well what sense of wonder the
news brought us knowing the sex of our
child felt as if we had cut in half the
number of possible futures our family
might find itself in there's a way in
which in the heart of pregnancy that was
very comforting but celebrating a
child's gender before it's born is a
tricky business it sets expectations for
who that child will
be it also leaves the unfortunate
impression that gender is the most
important thing to celebrate about that
child well first of all it is a very
important thing to celebrate about a
child and gender differences being sex
differences are deeply deeply important
to life and anyone who believes
otherwise is a fool if you don't think
there's a difference between men and
women you are a fool I don't just mean
in genitals I mean in terms of how men
and women think and act obviously there
is a difference but according to
Jennifer Boylan this is unacceptable
because we can't if you find out that
you have a boy in the womb you can't
just assume that that boy is gonna be a
boy maybe the boys gonna be a girl why I
quote as a late transitioning
transgender person I've experienced both
sides of a lot of this world I have been
both a best man and a matron of honor
and I can tell you that being a matron
of honor is a lot more fun being best
man felt a little bit like being a
security guard at a very sketchy
nightclub I've attended bachelor parties
as well as bridal showers at the bridal
shower my girlfriends and I mostly said
ooh and eyes we open up boxes of
high-end lingerie which was fun but
let's be honest Victoria's Secret is no
match for an amazing Larry as a
transgender person I thought my eyes
were pretty wide open when it came to
gender issues I tried to avoid defining
either of my children based on their sex
and encouraged them to find their own
path wherever it might lead but I was
still caught off guard with my older
child came out to me as transgender at
age 23 the news stunned me and left me
for a little while unable to speak then
I put my arms around her just as my own
mother had put her arms around me and
told her that I loved her just as my own
mother had said those words to me does
it ever occur to people that maybe how
you act in your life affects how your
children act and think about these
things and that I mean the number of
hardships a transgender person has to
undergo in this life the mental
hardships emotional hardships you have
to undergo even if you are actually
biologically predisposed toward gender
identity disorder it's extraordinary to
suggest that confusing a child for a
full generation about sex being
completely malleable has no impact on
the kids is insane and not to be able to
celebrate all this stuff is is pretty
and that's be able to celebrate the sex
of your child because you think your
child might end up being the opposite
sex is pretty upsetting it's pretty
upsetting in pretty ridiculous and
pretty cruel to the child because it
turns out sex differences are a
wonderful beautiful thing if you're not
real okay ting them in your child you
are making a very large mistake okay
time for a thing that I like and then
and I'm not sure I have any things I
hate more than that today so well do the
thing I like and then maybe if I
papers so things I like today is a great
book called wild liberalism failed out
by Patrick Jeannine there's a great
debate that has broken out on the right
about the Enlightenment and I am a pro
enlightenment guy I like the
Enlightenment but one of the critiques
of the Enlightenment is that the
Enlightenment basically valued
individual rights at the expense of
social fabric that essentially reduced
us all to individual atomized people who
don't have anything in common in terms
of culture in terms of history in terms
of social obligation and this has led to
a radical breakdown in society itself
that's the case Patrick's an inmate's
and wild liberalism failed I don't agree
with every elements of his critique but
I think it's a critique worth taking
seriously at a time when suicide is at a
record high and when seventy thousand
people a year in the United States are
dying from heroin overdose we have to
wonder whether the atomization that
accompanied liberalism in the
Enlightenment has had some downsides and
whether you can get the upsides of
classical liberalism without the
downside so long as you abide by a
vision of the social fabric that
actually matters the book is well worth
reading it is sophisticated take on
political theory that cuts against the
grain of modern politics which suggests
that atomized individualism is the only
way that the future will think I'm not
sure that's the case I think our current
political situation is good evidence in
the backlash check it out wild
liberalism failed by Patrick Danine well
worth the read okay time for a
Federalists paper so every week we do a
Federalist paper we were all the way up
to Federalist 52 this one's by Alexander
Hamilton this is about why we have
elections in the House of
Representatives every couple of years
his case is that every two years we have
these elections to prevent tyranny the
he starts off the Federalist paper by
talking about the definition of suffrage
in the Federal Constitution it basically
says that whatever is the state
legislature standard for suffrage
meaning voting in the state that also
has to be extended to elections for
congressional for Congress what you
don't want is the state setting a
standard where it says every male of
particular age at the time right this is
only males who were property owners in
many of these states all those males get
to vote for the state legislature but
only these seven people get to vote for
federal elections didn't want the state
being able to dictate the house
legislative constituency that way so it
says the definition of the right of
suffrage is very justly regarded as a
fundamental article of republican
government it was incumbent on the
convention therefore to define and
establish this right in the
to ssin it was done so in article 1
section 2 where it says the electors in
each state shall have the qualifications
requisite for electors in the most
numerous branch of the state legislature
meaning that you can't do what I talked
about before men hamilton talks about
why we should have elections every
couple of years he says in order to
decide on the propriety of this article
two questions must be considered first
whether biennial elections will in this
case be safe secondly whether they be
necessary or useful first as it is
essential to Liberty that the government
in general should have a common interest
with the people so it is particularly
essential that the branch of it under
consideration should have an immediate
dependence on an immediate in an
intimate sympathy with the people
frequent elections aren't questionably
the only policy by which this dependence
and sympathy can be effectually secured
now one of the reasons this is the case
is because travel in 1789 is a lot
different than travel now people have to
go back to their constituencies to
campaign every couple of years that's a
lot different than now like my my
feeling is that we should basically
disband Washington DC and let people
vote remotely from their districts I
think it actually be a lot better for
the country if people spend most of
their time in their districts as opposed
to most of their time hanging out with
the other muckety-mucks in Washington DC
Hamilton says it is a well received and
well founded Maxim that were no other
circumstances affect the case the
greater the power is the shorter ought
to be its duration
we mourn a lot of answerability we want
people being elected every couple of
years so that the people can turn over
the constituency of the house as often
as humanly possible and that is why we
vote every couple of years in the House
of Representatives okay well we will be
back tomorrow with I'm sure a lot more
to talk about the Flynn documents are
supposed to come down today so I'm sure
we'll be breaking those down and a lot
more i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018